here's brown a gator tips to tatum Hilda
thought for free and knocks it down
while he is shoot that ball so
beautifully as a free agent signed with
Boston in the summer he'll come to
screen attain it was open for another
three and knocks down another one that
spends on CJ his offering is fielded by
the Tyson fight State for three out of
the corner T boards for the horse
tonight with 10 points
entry pass didn't have pay smart picks
it off up the floor he comes tainted
wide open a transition and he hits
another three for Tina defended off the
ball by this year
data bakes right moves left and banks in
a three
the Goodyear is but the holidays are
available and they've got Brogdon that's
a pretty good tree garden rotation here
Tatum outside for three got it Wow he's
in that zone that we saw when he scored
41 on Sunday Tatum will bring that side
and a deep three gotta
four twenties really
Jason Tatum 4:3 knocking down another
one
he's been lighting up the league all
season especially over the last month no
different tonight